é
bota atenta contra a coca cola oi
ae
olá tudo isso aqui quem fala é dar que
sejam muito bem vindos à margem dele e
vejam só pessoal do que eu comprei o
curso vai ser muito louco olha aí eu
comprei uma motosserra mil isso é muito
grande é muito pesado que é muito
perigoso eu tô com medo de usar isso
como o youtube agora muito importante
mesmo tudo que vocês vão ver aqui neste
vídeo não tenta replicar em casa porque
isso é muito perigoso e até mesmo eu vou
ter um cuidado forçado não se brinca com
motosserra sem capacete sem luvas de
segurança têm tudo portanto isto só pode
dar certo eu passei dois dias a ler o
manual de instruções deste motosserra
então eu sou assim tudo o que é preciso
e como vocês poderão ler pelo título
hoje nós vamos fazer então motosserra
contra o mallorca
só comprei muitas bolas uma bola de
futebol que nem uma bomba do voleibol e
uma bola do passo que a outra coisa que
eu comprei que também vai ser muito
curioso explodir em uma obra no bem
grande é bem grande e deputado em podre
por dentro a atenção máxima em mínimas
não há cotas de honra viveu há mais
coisas que eu tenho aqui pessoal como
vocês sabem motosserra sempre procurar
madeira e claramente que eu não vou
andar por aí a cortar árvores né então
eu comprei um mini skype e hesketh aí
com você achava isso que a madeira
portanto vamos fazer um teste que tem
equipe só também papel as coisas
voltarão a lei eu acho que vai dar é
muito lixo que vai ter que vem por aí
mais uma louca que vai me ajudar né da
gnr que só terei de escolas vamos lá
começar mas antes de começar o show
quero que digam uma coisa muito
importante deixa muito aqui nos filhos
que quiserem ver mais vídeos motosserra
eu garanto coxa coca cola e amanhã pode
ser outra coisa ainda melhor que eu
deixei muito longe mesmo e como em baixa
o que vocês querem que o destrua com
esta nota 7 pode ser qualquer coisa o
carro do meu amigo é cama do meu amigo
isso o negócio aqui no canal pessoal
inscrevam se porque agora está sendo
vídeo todo o dia e clique neste link
também porque nem todas as notificações
é mesmo importante luvas prontas e agora
por produzir os melhores de minha cara
eu vou usar um capacete especificar e
matar a partida
eu até posso usar isso com o meu boné
mas antes de colocar o que eu passei
várias vezes ela funciona isso é muito
afiado e se serra olha isso pelo que eu
li no manual de instruções já só puxar
esta partilha para cima
o charity aqui é assim e agora é só
puxar a corda
é igual
eu tinha estado a nota se é
tem muita fumaça ninguém escolhe o
primeiro objeto de uma fonte ser uma
bola a bola da esquerda a bola para
tcheco que agora estas figuras bolas e
eu comprei que esta mesa que é uma
menina muito especial vocês já viram
alguma mesmo assim olha aí que estas
mini férias ea mesa abra olha isso ganha
lo em rixa
se eu fizer assim a bola ficar aqui
instalada então já dá pra fazer um
quarto aqui no bairro
a copa ortopé futebol
tô na cintura e é irónico olha isso o
retorno que se aplicar muito mal o corpo
ó
vocês viram isso olha só como ficou aqui
só com vocês puderam ver o poder da
motosserra estrago completamente as
bolas mas mora lá então outra coisa que
eu acho para voltar ainda melhor lei os
que têm mais velho porto vai custar
muito bem porque a motosserra foi
perguntar maneira então eu acho que um
pouco tabu no maiô que só quando ficou
claro que o nosso cai totalmente muito
bem preso aqui e bora lá vai lá
o dono do bar da galera aí como o metrô
porque a mesa eo alvejou como é que um
escritor em conjunto com uma dentada e
podia mesmo e aí eu ainda mesmo disse
coca cola se já podia mesa
ae
é
no porto o autor
mas não só como ficou o que foi escrito
e já tem uma pontuação em cima porque é
muito fácil sério eu só tenho que
aprender a colocar melhor é nem um
objeto é resolvido aí já temos a mesma
norma este que faço jardim todos que
assim vai e volta para casa contra o
papel
bocó
é o pt
op
por lá então pessoal tentar aqui com
três gols papel olha só
são três grupos
o botafogo
o tumor
por esse trabalho vai me an susto agora
pensei papel ainda vai se molhar com
coca cola ou vai ficar pior ainda solos
estão limpando tudo para lá então estava
próximo o objeto era só comento em baixa
o que vocês acham que vai sujar mais
durinha coca-cola abóbora o papel como é
que eu vou colocar a minha boca aqui não
vai dar no futuro não vai não vai dar
definitivamente preciso comprar um
suporte melhor este já não dá
este ano vai estar muito frágil e olha
que já partiu já pediu sua volta seja
contra a obra
op
é só ver só começaram sob o olho aí pra
toda despedaçada olha só estudar melhor
a irmã mãe do bem destruído ou lhes
corta aqui 1001 passada entrou muito bem
na bola o que eu acho que já só falta
uma coisa né
o que a coca cola não é só uma coca cola
são várias mas primeiro vou estar com
uma coca cola bora lá pessoal a coca
cola já está aqui bem coladinha eu acho
que vai dar certo e hoje estou coletando
lixo ou duda suja por dentro do núcleo
de taxas que só estragar uma toxina é
acordar amanhã quando a coisa e que nos
mantém dentro é isso e ex preso pelo
número da boca podre aqui meu
i ó campeão bom isso é algo muito ruim e
isso é muito louco
imaginem só consegue correr colo é meu
está tudo sujo no país
eu não sei nada eu não sei nada
paulo eu não sei nada do que ela vá para
o futebol europeu
vamos agitar todas todas as coca cola
mas não faz diferença é que por lá
quatro anos que assim vai
eu só preciso que elas fiquem todos
juntos
só vamos sentar à mesa olha aí assegura
parece que tá escuro para é eu acho que
aprovou o eca só fala sério deixei muito
aqui neste vídeo porque sei que vai ser
muito bonito eu espero eu que vai ter
uma idéia eu precisava de uma nova
ferramenta para abrir cofres né brincou
fran
só comento isso quiserem ver um vídeo de
eu tentar abrir um cofre com uma
motosserra e acho que não vai dar muito
resultado porque ferro com ferro da
áfrica
só estou nervoso eu tô tão nervoso que o
embaciado olha aí tem uma nuvem dentro
de mim e também uma novela não é do
óculo bola então pessoal motosserra
contra a coca-cola espero que dê certo
agora quando você se encontra a coca
cola oi
ayman taha
num dia muito difícil todo maio boninho
olha o país onde isso tudo como assim o
banho coca-cola agora eu tomei banho de
coca cola
meu deus ainda tenho aqui uma coca coxim
o juiz conclui agora sim
olha pra isso deu tudo muito certo olha
preços jardim vai ter que limpar tudo no
joelho está molhado com o qual eu é isso
que se tem muito em baixo coisas que
eram que o quarto com motosserra e suor
e nós aqui no canal e inscreva-se com
toda a força e clique no cineplace em
todos os vídeos a partir de agora
o
ae
e é isso ao fiquem bem e até a próxima
[Música]